i'm shane caldwell this is training an
autonomous pen tester using simulation
in deep rl i'm going to try to keep
talking into the mic and not turn my
head
uh so if you will forgive
a an understatement a huge
understatement i would say that ai can
do a lot of stuff it's been a pretty
prolific technology of the past decade
or so
it's really good in classifying pictures
of cats
it is currently the best go player in
the world
it has been two years away on driving
for 10 years or so
but you know between andres carpathi and
george hotz someone's going to get it
before too long
it can do whatever alpha fold is i
googled it i don't understand maybe you
do
but what can't ai do yet
it cannot yet hack the planet and i find
that unacceptable
uh so let's fix that today or at least
start moving in that direction
so just as an overview of where we're
going
we're going to talk about what pen
testing is and why we would bother
automating it we'll talk about
reinforcement learning as a potential
solution to do that automation
we'll talk about metasploit and sort of
its role as the
the correct level of abstraction i think
for uh automating pen testing
we'll talk about how to deal with how
bad rl wants data and how hard it is to
give it all the data it wants we'll talk
about the development of metasploit gym
which is a reinforcement learning
environment i've written that allows you
to
take your
python agents your neural nets and
interact with real networks using
metasploit we'll talk about what remains
to be done so first a little bit about
me i'm a recovering pen tester
i did the job for about two years
then i became a machine learning
engineer and am now
my intersection or my interest is that
intersection between
ai and security so just like two really
esoteric things
that people tend to not want to talk
about
so let's first start with what pen
testing is
in pen testing you are being paid to
hack people which is cool it's fun
your goal is to perform a security test
so your client has some network
infrastructure they want to know how
secure it is so you will try to
break in break it down and see what you
can find
so there are a lot of flavors so this
isn't the flavor that you do in
particular i hope you don't get mad at
me but in in the one that i was familiar
with when i was doing the job it was
black box right so you'll start with
what is available from the internet uh
that represents the attack surface or
the perimeter for the client
you'll you know attempt to exploit those
various pieces of the perimeter
you get through into the internal
network which tends to be way less
secure because they didn't think you
were going to get there and then you
sort of get into all sorts of trouble
you see how you know what kind of damage
you end up doing
at the end you submit a report this is
why they have you do this it's not just
for fun right they want a report showing
hey these are all the holes that you
found this is how you would remediate
them so you know someone who is slightly
more malicious than you doesn't actually
exploit them for profit
so if we can just do a pictorial example
once upon a time i was a skull in a
laptop and i was looking at the internet
looking at you know
i can go through the internet to a a
client's external web server right so
the world would be very secure if we
just stopped networking all our devices
but we found out they're like way more
useful that way so we tend to network
them anyway
so
assuming that this part goes well and i
can get into the perimeter
well then great now i'm now i'm red
skull on the box uh and that's useful
that's we'll call it remote code
execution uh you might think of it as
like a shell on the machine
what that allows you to do now that
you're on the box is look around right
you can see network interfaces you
couldn't otherwise you're now inside the
network you can see different machines
that are more local you can sort of move
laterally around the network and
continue to you know hack stuff
so the way this sort of works in
practice is you have a full network uh
so you have like 20 plus externally
available ips and then whatever is you
know on the actual client network once
you get inside there could be machines
for days
you have limited time to form the test
so it tends to be like
one to two weeks
and you have to balance or at least i
found i had to balance these two
distinct elements
the first was breadth so you're given
these
ips that are in scope you have to scan
them you have this like cider range or
maybe individual boxes
and you're looking for obvious
vulnerabilities when i say obvious
vulnerabilities i mean something that
someone has already exploited you know
if i google
name of service version of software and
exploit db something comes up that is
like code that runs that will exploit
this service
and my job is to look at literally as
many of these services as possible and
see like
say confidently at the end like you're
good or you're bad
if you missed something basic here
because you didn't do enough recon
that's going to be a huge problem your
client's not going to be happy with that
especially if someone comes in and
actually exploits that later so you've
basically failed them if you don't do
that breath very well
but the thing people like in this field
or at least the thing that i found that
i enjoyed and a lot of people i worked
with also enjoyed is something i would
call like more depth pen testing and
it's a little harder to define
it's like you're
you're doing your scans they take
forever
at one point something pops up like a
it's a web server but it's on a
non-standard port and you start
interacting with this web application
and as far as you can tell it's not like
a standard one it's like someone made it
custom and you're starting to like fuzz
the parameters you know you're getting
stacked traces that seem kind of
interesting like maybe exploitably
interesting like this is cool this is
the good stuff
that's where the dopamine came from for
me at least that was that was the good
brain juice
the problem is i would love to spend all
day on the depth thing
but to like
you know to do right by the client like
we said
you've got to make sure that breadth is
covered right that you did right by the
client so the adult thing to do is you
take the fun thing that you like a lot
and you time box it so if you have a
test that lasts a week maybe it'll take
like four hours of one of your days to
like try to do the fun thing and if it
doesn't work you got to step away you
know and get back to doing that breadth
stuff
so most of the time to do right by the
client you're doing breath type work but
the reason you like this job is because
the depth stuff
the solution actually it turns out is to
wait a couple of years until you have
junior pen testers to do the breadth
thing for you that did not strike me as
possible at the time because i'm very
impatient so i decided to quit my job go
back to grad school and study ml so we
could try to automate that breadth stuff
so i just do the depth thing all day
long
and during that time in grad school is
when i was more formally introduced to
reinforcement learning
so reinforcement learning is a field of
machine learning
a little different from supervisor
unsupervised learning and involves
focusing on agents
agents that can interact with their
environment
through different actions
and what they're doing when they
interact with this environment is
they're trying to maximize a reward
signal
it's got a great resume all basically
most of the really cool things in my
opinion at least the ai's done over the
past like decade have all been
reinforcement learning so if you like
alphago if you like the best go player
on the planet then you're into
reinforcement learning uh the open ai
dotabot atari these are like problems
that we used to consider pretty like
human kind of problems and rl's good at
knocking them out
but what do you need what needs to be
true before you can apply reinforcement
learning to your problem
first you need to be able to break the
problem up into an action space so for a
given turn at a given time step what
moves can the agent make
then you need a state space so at what
level of abstraction will you represent
your environment what is the agent going
to get to see before it makes a decision
about what to do next
and then both of these have to be
vectors or matrices because that is the
language of you know deep learning
models that's just what it is and you
have to have a reward signal so let's
look at a super simple example connect
four
uh so the action space pretty obvious
right you got eight places to drop a
checker there's only so much you can do
in connect four great we can represent
that as a vector pretty easily zero one
zero zero zero et cetera uh that could
indicate dropping a check from the
second column it's one by a vector we're
good that's an action
the environment on the other hand you
know we could represent it as an eight
by eight board
so you know what we know about this
board is that it is eight by eight and
you know there is either a red checker a
yellow checker or an open space so we
can kind of arbitrarily choose okay red
is negative one
yellow is one and open space is 0.
there you go
the reward signal is also pretty
straight forward
you have a one-on-one game you like to
win you hate to lose you can sort of
dole out your award that way
so the agent will start very bad it'll
pick moves essentially at random but as
it starts to play more of these games
it'll start to correlate certain
versions of its environment and in
certain actions it's chosen that result
in a win or a loss
it'll start to learn like oh when i do
this i win in this situation that's
great
so
with all that stuff sort of set up you
can now have a pretty you can kind of
take your pick of any deep reinforcement
learning algorithm that has been made
you know in the last couple of years
through self play take these two agents
they play against each other
you will
in like three hours on your laptop have
a greater than human player at uh
connect four which is cool not as cool
as hacking so
let's sort of uh but let's talk about
the benefits of rl right so it's a very
general problem formulation right uh you
can't you know make everything look like
a classification problem that neural
nets are good at but like agents
interacting in an environment and like
doing stuff that's like more general
there are a lot of things that could fit
that sort of description right and it as
we discussed its resume is great it's
crushed some problems that we thought
required human intelligence we used to
say like man if you could play chess
that'd be ai right and now chess is like
chess is lunch man we can do more so
that seems like a good place to start
but it has its drawbacks
rl has its detractors and they're not
wrong either
it's extremely data hungry so when i
show you the resume of rl you're looking
at a lot of things that are games right
that can be run it faster than real time
you can collect a lot of data very
quickly
it also requires a cleanly delineated
action in state space which ends up
being a more difficult and philosophical
question than you might initially
believe
um
and it's difficult to train due to
reward hacking and this is we're going
to look oh the video still works we love
that
so before open ai got into large
language models they used to be into
training reinforcement learning agents i
thought that was a cooler that's just me
but this is like the canonical example
of reward hacking what reward hacking is
is when you give an agent a reward for
something and it finds out how to do the
thing that gets it reward but not the
thing you wanted it to do in this case
the agent is a boat it's supposed to win
the boat racing game
but like we said at the beginning those
random actions you pick are probably not
going to lead to success right so if you
only give a reward when the agent wins
the race well you're never gonna get
anywhere you're never gonna win the race
so they gave out reward for picking up
this little speed boost this power up
uh
because you know if you go fast you
probably win the race right
well this agent uh is a genius and it
figured out how to just get in a perfect
loop that allowed it to pick up like
three speed boosts
and just continue to do that
uh
and so is wire heading at this point it
had no other desire for reward you can
see all the other sort of boats just
like lapping it
it's kind of tough to get one of these
to train in a way that it is aligned
with sort of the the goal that you have
so that brings us to pen testing right
so i really wanted to automate pen
testing and i really thought
reinforcement learning was the solution
but determining the action state space
was challenging
for those of you who've done the job
uh you know that there are a lot of
tools involved in network plan testing
there's a lot to think about so picking
a level of abstraction to sort of work
on that is like
uh not so abstract that it's meaningless
and not so like down in the nitty-gritty
that you are orchestrating like tens of
thousands of tools and like keeping
their state and like figuring out what
that even means like that the software
engineering challenge alone of cajoling
all those tools would like sort of
kept me from working on this for about
two years because i just didn't know how
to move forward with it
then covet happened and i had a lot more
free time
and like three months into that i was
reading network security papers at 2am
as you do and i came across this guy
jonathan schwartz he was writing on his
work
he was doing simulations for security
um and in his talk
um sort of or his thesis that i'm
browsing through he's sort of arguing
for why simulation is okay uh and
in his argument he's like you might
think this is too abstract but you know
we're in the security realm we're
already moving towards abstraction so
take metasploit for example people who
use metasploit they use it
professionally all the time you don't
need to know how the exploit works right
you're working on this certain level of
abstraction where you just sort of know
this is the service i'm attacking this
is the port you know this is the ip
those lower level details are handled
and those that's still doing real pen
testing
i was like that's a really good idea
we should do that so i in that i felt
like i found the perfect like layer of
abstraction to sort of apply
reinforcement learning to that problem
and that was the that the metasploit
level uh so let's talk about what
metasploit is real quick
so metasploit is this open source
framework for pen testing uh it is a
like a bunch of ruby code comprised of
modules to sort of uh do everything you
might do during a penetration test it's
a super common tool
so handle scanning so you're looking at
your targets these machines what's their
operating system what are the ports et
cetera
you can exploit common vulnerabilities
there are over 592 different services
that can be exploited they're more
written all the time and it's just like
thousands of people writing these pr's
for like oh there's a new like proof of
concept let me put that in my display
that's just like a common thing which is
great privilege escalations that's if
you have a lower privileged shell you've
exploited a box but you're running in
like a normal user context you really
want to be running in a root context so
they have tools for that and then
grabbing loot so to pull sensitive files
off of hosts generally as a way to prove
that you were on the box that you said
you were on to a client
it also might contain information that
allow it gives you sort of further
access to the network and it's really
easy you select a module you configure
some parameters that are related to the
host most generally what ip what port
what do you want me to do when i get
there and you execute and you're you're
off to the races
metasploit also keeps a lot of state
this makes sense because when you are
pen testing if you don't have an audit
trail that is like you know with a
bullet
you're in trouble because when you're on
someone else's network even if they're
paying you to be there if something
breaks while you're there
it's your fault as it turns out no
matter what you were doing
so
as a consequence metasploit has a really
slick database with all the hosts you've
encountered during your test all the
services running on all those hosts all
the exploits you've run or tried to run
all the files you got off the machines
any credentials for those machines
that sounds a lot like a state in action
space to me that's a level of
abstraction i can work with that
involves actually you know exploiting
boxes so i was satisfied with that and
so
to that end i built the metasploit gym
which is a reinforcement learning
environment that allows dprl algorithms
to interact with networks of real
machines using metasploit as a sort of
conduit
this is possible because metasploit
though written in ruby has a grpc
service which gives you access to its
api you can do basically everything you
could do from the terminal command line
automated and this guy dan who's last
name i'm going to mispronounce i'm sorry
dan dan mckinry uh okay he developed pi
metasploit 3 which gives this excellent
api for handling all the communication
with this rpc service it probably
knocked like six months off my
development time he's a hero
we love him let's talk about the state
space that i made so you guys can argue
with me over whether it's complete or
not
first so our environment that we're
representing here the sort of atomic
data structure here is going to be the
host right so we're going to represent
the host as a flat vector
and there will be many hosts
first we have to pick we want to store
the information of the address in the
subnet and make that available to our
agent
uh sort of a limitation to call out here
is that every time you pass your
environment to your agent so your agent
looks at a vector or a matrix rather
representing your environment has to be
the same size so when i start training a
uh a net
and when i start training an agent i
have to make the decision like how many
subnets and how many hosts per subnet
are we going to build for here because
each
you're going to get a matrix of rows
each of these is going to be a host and
i have to decide how many hosts ahead of
time because i can't make that matrix
bigger later so for example if i say two
subnets eight hosts on the subnets well
that's 16 possible hosts it'll start all
zeroed out and as i see more hosts in
the network or as my agency's more
hosting the network i'll add them but
they're sort of a hard limit on size
which is you know it is what it is it's
a limitation
loot that's an easy one so we'll have
one index of this host vector that's
just for loot it's an integer every time
you get one
you sort of increment that number
that's easy
operating system we'll have a single
number another binary flag is this unix
is this windows that'll be really
relevant to what kind of exploits we
pick as it turns out
i didn't include mac because
there aren't that many maximum
vulnerabilities like you could roast me
for that but in terms of what i was
working with it's true
credentials another single number sort
of binary flag
so one if you got creds zero if you
don't that's great we can store a
reference to the credentials within the
metasploit gym environment so if you if
the agent chooses to use an exploit that
requires these credentials then we can
just provide that at run time otherwise
the agent just knows i have some
services this is sort of where you start
making a lot of big decisions
obviously if i made it the vector big
enough to include like every sort of
port
and then whether it was running tcp or
udp that would be a very very large
vector that's not a proof of concept
that's too hard so i picked some ports
and i did that
through the rigorous method of letting
nmap decide nmap publishes they're like
it's like the biggest scanning tool on
the planet
and they publish a list of like hey
these are the ports that people scan
top 20. so i was like great give me the
top 20 tcp services that's what i'm
interested in
so we have
20 elements in this vector that are just
for like hey these are the services that
are on these ports
you know binary flags all around and we
have a separate data structure to handle
port mapping so say ftp is on a
non-standard port that's fine the agent
just knows ftp is there and will handle
that poor configuration when it comes
time to execute and exploit
now it's the same service again this is
the size issue right we need our host to
be a consistent size so if the same
service is on multiple ports we're just
going to ignore it which is like not
great for services like http there might
be like a bunch but we'll just pick the
first one we find and we'll throw the
rest out
vulnerabilities those are important so
if we've exploited the vulnerability on
the machine or it
or tried we want to make sure we store
that as well so for each action we have
we're going to you know
add that to our vector as well
so we'll have 20 different or i do
currently have 20 different uh exploits
that metasploit gym supports
which are like
broken up between
exploits privilege escalation loot
gathering scanning all that stuff
and then privileges that's super
important to know so
when we talk about privileges in the
security context we're generally talking
about what context are we running in do
we have system access can we do whatever
we want or are we in some limited
context so we'll keep access
that information as well will be exposed
to our agent
and then we that's for one vector right
that's one host so how do we make a
network matrix well you start with the
host vector and then you put another
host vector and then you stack those up
so you got a network matrix
and then we'll throw one additional row
on the bottom
and that will give the results of the
last action whether you were successful
or not that's just going to give the
agent a little more information as to
like hey you did the right thing you did
the wrong thing
the action space straightforward i
already said we have 20 different
exploits the action space is basically
pick a host pick an action pick a
service you're ready to go
that is also represented as a flat
vector
reward reward was something i just sort
of tried to reverse engineer from how
good things felt when i was pen testing
which is sort of arbitrary i guess but
uh gathering novel information is good
in pen testing so if you learned about a
new machine i'll give you five for that
if you check and exploit against the
machine and it'll run as far as
metasploit is concerned you get one
gathering loot is going to give you one
reward per unique file and five reward
for password hashes
when i say this is for novel information
what i'm saying is we're trying to avoid
that like boat spinning in circle
picking up speed powerups thing right if
we gave it out each time you scanned
then you know any agent under the sun
would just learn like i'm just going to
keep scanning that thing this is free
like this tastes great
so only for novel information and the
same will be true of exploits so if you
exploit a unique vulnerability on a host
you haven't exploited it on yet that's
going to be 10 reward and then if you
get super user privileges that's all the
marbles you got root we love that we're
going to be 20 reward for that so
there you go
so we have this environment uh what are
we going to train it on we'll start with
by using we'll start with metasploitable
so if you're in the security space at
all you know exploitable machines are
like super exploitable they're
they're very bad in terms of security
they're essentially test machines
wherein if you pick like random actions
from metasploit there's a good chance
you're going to pop a shell on that box
they're easy to exploit but that's good
actually because you know think back
again to the boat example they had to
find a way to give it reward that wasn't
associated with winning because just
picking random actions is not going to
get you anywhere in the start but if a
machine is super exploitable then
picking random actions is more likely to
lead to like actual reward in the way we
want it so that's great actually
in terms of training speed this is where
things get a little dicey so you're
running real commands and real exploits
against real machines that's slow
actually i don't know if you've ever run
an nmap scan on every port that a
machine has it takes forever man
and to simplify turns each command needs
to be entirely finished before i read in
state this is like a super common
problem i had early on as i would kick
off a scan and then i just like keep
doing actions or whatever and then my
scan would complete after i'd taken like
a random like ssh brute force action or
something so the agent's like oh i ran
ssh brute force and now i learned all
this stuff about the box that was great
that's not great
we'd like to make it asynchronous but to
ease it up we're going to say you know
you must completely finish the command
and you're running virtual machines that
you have to reset to a known good state
after every episode that also takes some
time
so i you know this is uh this is just
running on my local machine i found that
i was able to collect 256 time steps
every seven minutes which sounds okay
until you look at the dota bot that open
ai made
it was getting 256 time steps every
minute for each of its 57 000 workers
i don't know if you guys are good at
math i'm not but they were getting way
more data than me uh so we have to go
faster how are we gonna get more data uh
fast
simulation i think is a good idea here
so we can take all the same abstractions
that we already made to get our sort of
medisploy gym running and we can build
it out as a mathematical model instead
of a simulation or instead of a real
network to allow us to train faster so
we're going to keep the action space and
observation space one to one this is
crucial so as far as our agent is
concerned
it doesn't know whether it's interacting
with the simulation or a real
environment
so how do we do that uh math people
figured that out for us actually a while
ago it's called a partially observable
markov decision process what do you need
for those when you need states great we
got states we picked states already
we're good there
uh we need actions we already have
actions uh we need t a set of
conditional transition probabilities oh
we don't have that yet actually but
that's the one we need to do and the
reward function is going to be the same
so when we talk about conditional
transition probabilities what we're
saying is for a given action
in a given state there needs to be a
probability of success or failure and
then given success and given failure you
need to know what the state looks like
in each case so for example i can
simulate a machine that is running ssh
and then i can run
the ssh command against it and then i
will decide what is the probability that
that was successful and what is it what
reward does it get if it was successful
this enriches jonathan schwartz's work
actually the same person whose paper i
read that sort of inspired all this
metasploit stuff i've simply expanded it
to be compatible with metasploit's data
model so interact with their own
machines
so you can generate a machine over yaml
it's kind of easy we'll look at this
alien points so for example we can say
this host is running ssh
it has an exploit that it's vulnerable
to which is this ssh exploit
it's a linux specific one and if you run
it there if you run you know the ssh
vulnerability there is an 80 chance that
it's going to be successful
and implied in this but not state is is
if you run like an ftp exploit against
an ssh that's zero percent right that's
we're not gonna let that happen
what that means is because that is
opaque to the agent we can use the
probability to sort of uh start to bias
the action of the agent towards certain
actions so we can learn super basic
stuff that it would take us a long time
to learn if we were learning it's real
machines for example ssh vulnerabilities
tend to work against ssh not just sort
of randomly
so we can teach it both the sort of the
actions that certain services should be
associated with in the general loop of
hey you should scan then you should
exploit and you should get privilege
escalation and then you should scan new
subnets and we can do that all in
simulation
so you want to see a demo right
uh i trained a deep q learning agent
against metasploitable 2 using the
metasploit gym environment i created
i ran it against a random agent so for
those of you not familiar with
reinforcement learning research the way
you show if you like did something
is pick actions at random and then you
see if you beat that if you be random
you're doing great
academically speaking so that's what we
did
so each agent had the same sort of
action space it was working in the same
environment
and we ran that for 100 episodes which
means at the end of an episode you're
going to reset the environment to the
beginning and run it again
let's look at bar charts
so the average award over 100 episodes
uh the random agent just sort of picking
stuff did get lucky sometimes it ended
up with like on average uh 11 you know
points of reward again not exploitable
is like very exploitable you can just
pick random stuff and it'll work out for
you the dq network on the other hand got
35 reward on average which is the
maximum available from the environment
and then the number of episodes root was
achieved so the number of uh sort of
episodes wherein it was ended not
because we ran out of time steps but
because hey you got root on you know the
only box i care about we can move on
uh for the random agent that was about
one-fifth of the time and for the deep q
network it was always
and then the average steps to root so
how many time steps did it take to sort
of get to root on this metasploitable
box uh the random agent has no you know
strategy it's just picking random stuff
so it took on average about 10 if it got
there
and the deep q network learned this kind
of like two-step
this sort of minimal step that i uh that
i wanted it to learn which was cool
uh and let's look at a play-by-play just
to make that sort of concrete uh i'm not
gonna do a live demo because i'm you
know i'm crazy but not that crazy uh and
i don't trust hotel internet man i'm a
security guy so we're going to start by
looking i'm going to show you
screenshots of the terminal of sort of
what it looks like over the course of
one of these episodes
so this is time step zero we're looking
at a target ip you see the ip there host
name metasploitable 2.
so this is the view from within
metasploit at the beginning so you're at
time step 0 you know no hosts you don't
know anything
so faced with this and in an in-scope ip
that i provide
the agent will first choose to do a port
scan good choice
uh and at the end of that port scan it
has a list of sort of all the services
that are running
there are a lot because it's
intentionally vulnerable
and then for the two-step or for time
step two it will choose to execute this
particular
ftp vulnerability
uh and it will be successful so from
metasploit you'll sort of see this
command shell pop up and then when you
look at that command shell
you'll connect to it you'll be like who
am i and it'll be like rude and you'll
be like sweet like this is great
so it did it in this sort of uh baby
case right metasploitable is a very
intentionally vulnerable machine
i did not solve pen testing just because
i can automatically sort of
teach an agent to do this
so future work could involve adding sort
of all of the exploits that medisplay
has so a full action space
and then programmatically creating more
realistic network scenarios so
uh a one machine does not a network make
uh network topologies are a little more
complicated than that and they they have
like a variety of different uh sort of
shapes that we'd want to know about
and do that early training on the
simulator as i discussed and then move
to real machines that are created like
scripted with a vagrant or whatever to
actually fine-tune our weights then
pen testing is also an interesting
environment to explore the practical
alignment problem so the alignment
problem is when uh you've heard it
really smart people are like super
intelligence is going to turn us all
into paper clips because it's going to
maximize its reward by turning people
into paper clips and you're like i don't
know about that the classifier thinks my
cat's a toaster so that's not really at
the top of my list of concerns right now
but
alignment research is real and it's a
really interesting area of technical ai
safety we're looking at general problems
of like like the boat that picked up the
uh the power up instead of
winning the race of aligning the sort of
the reward we're giving agents with our
actual goals right
and pen testing to like make this work
in production environments you'd have to
solve some of those problems so for
example uh discretion is the better part
of valor for pentesters there was many
times when i was working a job and i
would see a service that looks like
super exploitable then i'm googling this
service and it's like yeah you can run
this exploit but it might crash the box
i'm not going to do that
my professional liability insurance is
expensive
so i'm going to send an email i'm going
to put it in the report anyway an agent
seeking reward is just going to exploit
it you know come what may it wants that
sweet sweet reward that's a problem
there's also
another problem would be like
if i see if i'm a pen tester i'm on a
network and i see a bunch of client
machines right machines people are using
for email excel whatever
and i see a vulnerability being
expressed i you know as the pentester
assuming that's in scope i'm going to
pop
two of those boxes max the first to see
that i was right and the second to
verify that like they probably all share
this configuration and then i'm going to
write a report that says hey all 350 of
your machines this probably applies to
them
but my bot here would just be like 300
free reward juice yeah man and it would
pop every single one of them and then
when i talked to my client was like hey
you're right you guys have to clean
every single box on your server actually
like every single box in your network
because uh i wanted a lot of reward then
again i'm going to get fired at best
it works the professional liability
insurance is going to come in clutch so
this is like very much uh l2 autonomous
pen testing let's say
but some takeaways now uh a lot of
interesting ai research goes undone
without the infrastructure to work on it
right so like making the gym was mostly
about sort of getting a data model from
metasploit that i thought would work for
an agent and then sort of cajoling it
through this rpc service to when an
action is selected make sure that it's
run that's all software engineering
right the the ai parts of this project
like actually training the model took me
like
a week
they're writing the software so i could
train that model against it took me like
six months and like years of thinking
about it so if you have a domain that
you care about um
in programming skills this seems like a
good audience for that
you can create infrastructure that makes
it easier to
bring ai research to your field so if
you have a gym for your problem like
you're into i don't know team fortress 2
you make a team fortress 2 gym like now
people will write you know stuff to
interact with that you've now lowered
the barrier for entry
and also
you might want to use metasploit gym
this is a functional programming crowd
so you won't understand this but i was
like passing state around a lot
while i was writing this so it got
uglier over time
i'm not ready to open source it yet but
i will by the end of the year when it's
a little less runs on my machine
when it's ready it'll go here under
freak ai metasploit gym and i'm going to
post this slide deck on slack after this
so don't worry if you can't see it
so if the work sounds interesting to you
to like really do it all the stuff i'm
talking about like i need to handle this
full action space and i need to script a
lot of machines and different network
topologies and train a distribution that
like to create a distribution that is
representative of real life and then
train an agent against that that's a lot
of stuff so if you're an engineer deep
learning researcher you're into cicd
devops you're a pen tester let's work
together this is all like open source
stuff i'm doing in my free time and i
would love to work on it with other
people so send me an email or join this
discord link and i will be there and we
can talk shop
so thank you
if you have questions or want to
contribute to metaplay jim
there's my email i spend like way too
much time on twitter and you can find me
there and then again there is the ai
discord where i'm hoping we can do this
work going forward
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you